We're gonna lose him. Dropping in.
It's Cable, 12 O'clock.
New plan! Use all of your imaginary powers to stop Cable from killing that kid.
Where is he? I can't see him.
He's on top of you.
He's going in through the back!
Oh, God, he's inside!
- You hear yourself, right?
Accidental double entendres!
Got it! No, I don't....
Wade, you have a good heart.
With training you can be X-Man.
I am not X-Men material at all.
First off, I'm not even a virgin.
I ain't letting Cable kill this kid, but I can't do this alone.
I'm an X-Man.
- Trainee!
SHUT IT!
Stay back or Justin Bieber dies!
Ha! Justin Bieber, he called you Justin Bieber.
You're no hero.
You're just a clown
dressed up as a toy.
So dark! You're sure you're not from the DC Universe?
My name is Cable. I'm here for the kid.
Kids give us a chance to be better than we used to be.
He needs you.
Daddy's got this.
I ain't letting Cable get to him, but I can't do this alone.
I need your help, ladies.
Understatement of the year?
- You're absolutely right!
I like this guy!
Give him a chance.
I ain't letting Cable kill this kid.
We're gonna form a super-duper group.
Our group will be forward thinking, gender neutral,
who will be known as X-Force!
Isn't that a little derivative?
You're absolutely right!
I don't know much about this Cable fellow,
but I guarantee he hasn't killed as money people as melanoma has.
Paul, zip it!
My name is Peter.
Upoznaj... - Domino.
What's your stick?
- I'm lucky.
Luck isn't a super power.
Yes, it is.
- No, it's not.
You underestimate my powers.
Nice! But not a super power.
Yes, it is.
Let's meet in the middle and say - no, it isn't.
You're hired.
- Lucky me.